nos piden que construyamos la media triz
del segmento ave aquí tenemos el
segmento ave y debemos construir su
media tris es decir una recta
perpendicular a ave que pase por su
punto medio para eso nos dan dos
herramientas nos dan compás y regla
déjame utilizar el compás ahí tenemos un
compás es más bien como un compás
virtual verdad un compás real pues sería
tendría su punta metálica y su punta de
grafito pero bueno lo que voy a hacer es
este compás virtual lo voy a centrar en
a y voy a ponerle de radio la longitud
del segmento ave y ahora voy a poner
otro compás para bueno voy a utilizar el
compás para poner otro círculo centrado
en be y con radio también igual a ave y
una vez que hago eso se crean dos puntos
este de aquí y este de acá con los
cuales puedo trazar mi media triz ahora
pongo una regla pongo un punto de este
lado otro punto de este lado
y listo con esto ya tengo trazada la
media triz déjame bajar un poco para que
lo veas mejor ahí está tenemos esta
recta que es perpendicular y pasa por el
punto medio déjame comprobar la
respuesta
muy bien es correcta